Hi, Meredith,
(audience clapping)
I have been cyber-stalking you all weekend.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe that.
I'm so excited to meet you Drew,
thank you for having me.
I'm so excited to meet you too.
And it's really interesting
to meet the woman behind the woman.
And did you know that you would end up
in the fashion industry
or was it like a pivot?
I mean, how did you get into this?
Yeah, I definitely did not think
that I was going to be working in fashion.
It was never part of my world growing up
except in my fantasy world in my head.
But I actually grew up dancing
and I went on to study psychology.
I wanted to be a dancer for a time, I wasn't good enough.
Oh well, that's okay.
And random series of life events
led me to working with Michelle Obama, which is crazy.
Not something I would've ever imagined,
expected, even dreamt about.
Like, it wasn't in my wildest dreams.
Well, in honor of Beauty Week,
the two of us have teamed up-
Yes.
To guide one of our VFFs
who was wanting some help
in the beauty and fashion department.
So let's take a look at what we did with Amy.
(lively music)
Hi everyone.
My name is Amy, I live in Riverside, California
with my husband and two children.
I would really love some help
in the beauty and fashion department.
I've been stuck in a makeup rut for almost 20 years now.
I would love some advice on better colors
to go with my skin tones and my eyes and hair color.
As far as fashion's concerned, I tend to be quite casual,
so I would love an upgrade,
a fancier outfit that I could wear on a special date night.
I'm only five feet tall
so I'm also looking for something
that would be flattering on my shorter stature.
Drew, Meredith, can you please help me out?
(upbeat music)
Hi Amy.
Hi, I'm so excited to meet you.
So if you're ready to open your box,
I am gonna take you through everything
that I personally handpicked for you.
This is the It foundation, It Cosmetics,
their famous CC Cream with 50 SPF for you.
Perfect.
It looks really pretty.
Now I noticed that you said
you were open to a powdered blush,
so I got you this.
This is the company I have.
It's Flower Beauty.
It's rosy, it's perfect for your skin tone,
and it's giving the right amount of light reflection.
This is a new pencil for us at Flower.
So I got you this Smokey Topaz.
I also brought you our Amethyst.
Which one are you more drawn to, pun intended?
Can we go for the Amethyst?
Yes, perfect.
My favorite trick
is you open up the inside of the upper waterline
and you go all the way over
and it massively opens up your eyes.
Okay.
Ooh, that looks good.
And then I went with a brown mascara for you.
I'd like you to give yourself
like two or three coats of this.
Okay.
One coat of mascara is never enough.
With your blue eye color,
I thought these beautiful taupe,
and bronzy, and brown tones were really good.
Now grab your Charlotte Tilbury Pillow Talk lipstick.
This is a beautiful color.
(Drew gasps)
Oh, I'm so glad you're pleased.
I love a nice neutral rosy tone.
Oh my gosh, Amy, I think you look so pretty.
Hi Amy.
It's great to meet you.
(gentle upbeat music)
So I sent over some options for you to try on,
so why don't we start an open that first box?
Ooh, yay!
Amy, what do you think?
I love it.
I love the style.
This looks amazing on you.
It was so important to pick things
that have the right proportion for your body.
Another thing I love about this dress
is that it's secondhand
and it's a great way to shop
if you wanna reduce your impact on the environment,
and also if you want to save some money.
Let's open up that second box.
Oh my gosh.
You look so good.
This is amazing.
It just seems fun, kind of flirty
and I love the style.
I love this print with your hair and your skin.
Okay Amy, third and final box.
Let's do it.
Oh my gosh, you're so cute.
This is bold, it's new, I really like it.
Very '60s inspired.
We've got the A-line shape, the little cap sleeve,
a really interesting detail at the neck line
that we're gonna see.
I know what my favorite is,
I know what I think you're gonna choose,
so I can't wait to see.
All right,
(audience clapping)
and Amy is here to show us her final look,
first the make-up.
(audience cheering)
Amy, you look so beautiful.
How are you feeling about the new application?
I absolutely love it.
Especially the brown tones,
I feel like it really does match my hair and my skin tone
so much better than traditionally what I was wearing,
and the lipstick perfect for daytime or night.
I absolutely love it.
Thank you so much.
All right, Meredith over to you.
Great.
Yeah.
Ooh.
(audience cheering)
By the way, your shape and skin look just gorgeous.
Yes, I love the proportion of this,
and we've got this part of the body showing,
which is elongating for her.
Amy is truly a petite size
and so showing this skin in the way that we did
elongates the leg as well.
You look stunning.
Gorgeous.
Thank you.
I absolutely love it.
Especially, I love the fluttery sleeves,
the print.
I love blues so this is just perfect.
What's your mentality going into date night now?
I am so ready.
Ooh.
I have so much planned.
(audience cheering)
Well, Amy, I mean, listen, we've all like been with you
and now I've been investing,
can you please tell us how the date night went?
I really like to follow up.
Absolutely, would love to do that.
Okay, cool.
And Meredith, what an honor and a pleasure to work with you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I would love
to do this again.
Yes.
Amy and Meredith-
Thanks.
thank you so much.
(bright upbeat music)